- Every day is like an Etch A Sketch.
You sketch your etch.
And then you take it off
by shaking the board.
- I know very little about makeup.
- I know about blush,
I know about mascara,
I know about, that's it.
(up-tempo funky jazz music)
- I don't know where to start.
- Apply foundation first.
- There's no makeup in here.
It's just a mirror and a pad.
Oh! Haha!
There's two doors!
- That's way too much.
- Just looks kinda like sunscreen.
- I feel like this is
making me look worse.
- This is also what very prestigious men
in the 1700s used to do.
That's not a fact, that's a guess.
- Don't get it in your eye.
I feel like I'm (beep) Photoshopping
myself in real life right now.
- You realize how wrinkly you are.
- I don't know what a concealer does
but I'm gonna figure it out.
- Boop. Okay, concealed!
- I got a little there and
then you just kinda like...
Yeah, that's, dude, I'm right!
- Awww, someone been pinchin' his cheeks!
- Who's a happy boy?
- You know going into this I didn't want
to look like some 1950s female movie star.
- Are you supposed to, like, color it in?
- You don't put it on your top lip,
you just put it on your bottom lip?
- You do that, right?
- Where's a tissue?
I know I'm supposed to
bite on that (beep).
- I can't get the little ones.
- I've always wanted, like, a little more
dark and defined eyebrows.
- Girls do this right?
- Is this the thing that you
put underneath your eyelashes?
- "Retractable pencil, for lips."
Ha-ha! They're labelled!
- So I kinda put too
much lipstick liner on.
- If you just (beep) up,
you just add more makeup.
- Goddammit!
(funky upbeat jazz music)
- Yeah, honestly, it just,
it just feels like I'm putting on a mask.
- I became what I feared the most.
A monster.
- You know when I see a
woman and they wear makeup
I'm gonna be like, "Hey,
you spent time on that."
- It's not easy to get everything right.
- That's something I never thought about
is feeling the pressure
of needing to do something
like this every single day just to fit in.
- Don't think of this as a chore,
think of it as a way to express yourself.
And have fun with it.
And if you don't want to do it (beep) it.
- Let dudes be a part of it society!
I want in on your makeup world!
- This used to be my face (laughs).
- [Voiceover] Hi!